The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So I am really happy to
say that we've got SWERY.
Do you go with SWERY or Swery65?
SWERY: SWERY please.
PROFESSOR: SWERY.
Swery65's Twitter.
Your Twitter account.
SWERY: Yes.
INTERPRETER: So a developer.
He's visiting us from Japan,
visiting for the Video Game
Orchestra, which Shota-- is
he in the room right now?
SHOTA: I'm here.
PROFESSOR: There he is-- is
organizing that orchestra.
They're playing tomorrow.
That's right?
Yeah.
So we sent you
the code for that.
So please, if you're
interested in attending,
please do attend that.
It'll be really fun.
They'll be playing some of
the music from SWERY's most
recent game.
SWERY's from Access Games?
SWERY: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And previous
games he's made
include Spy Fiction,
Deadly Premonition,
and the Deadly Premonition
director's cut.
And a few others.
SWERY: To Japan.
Ace Combat.
Or [? Ganda. ?] Something.
PROFESSOR: So from Namco Bandai.
Those were Namco games.
Yeah.
So he's made a bunch of
different types of games.
We really like, at
the lab, we really
enjoy the Deadly
Premoniton game.
It's a great open-world
simulation game
that it plays a lot
differently than if you're used
to the normal Grand Theft Auto.
So if you haven't played
that, Deadly Premonition,
he'll be talking about
some of those games today.
But definitely
check out YouTube,
and check out playing that.
We have it at the lab.
So if you'd like to use the
lab and play that game at all,
you're more than welcome to.
They're going to also be
demonstrating their most
recent game on the Kinect once
we get our tech issues fixed.
So we'll start with lecture.
We'll have some Q&A
at the end of that,
and hopefully
we'll have a chance
to play their latest game.
So I'm going to give you this.
INTERPRETER: You can
just clip it anywhere?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, just clip
it like-- near the top
of your-- yeah.
INTERPRETER: OK.
PROFESSOR: And feel
free to hold it
if you don't have
anywhere else to put it
INTERPRETER: OK.
SWERY: Hi.
Nice to meet you guys.
I can't speak English well.
Sorry.
I need a translator.
INTERPRETER: Hi.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: I'll be
speaking in Japanese.
So I will translate.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: As the teacher
has said, that he makes games.
So in order to
accommodate everyone
who might not know
the games, we've
presented this
picture over here.
Can you hear me OK?
Is this good?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: These
are all the games
that he's worked on previously.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: You're familiar
with these games, here?
You know, some were only
released in Japanese market,
also.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[APPLAUSE]
INTERPRETER: We've been making
games for about 20 years, just
like these games up here.
And today, we'd like to talk
about the very newest game
using the Xbox Kinect
in the front there.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
this is basically
the structure of today.
We want to start
with a small lecture.
If we can get the video going--
PROFESSOR: They're here
to set that up right now.
INTERPRETER: Yay!
We can play it, and then
have a short Q&A at the end.
SWERY: Yep.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So for some
of you who might not know,
D4 is a game that was
designed for Xbox One Kinect,
so that you can play using your
motions from the very beginning
all the way to the very end
in an action-adventure kind
of story.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So this
is a type of game
that you actually don't have to
hold the control in your hand.
Everything is hand-motion based.
So it has this sensor with
the Xbox One Kinect bar.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So the
Kinect, it actually
takes a skeletal image of you.
And then, using that,
it allows for it
to detect the motion of the
person who's playing the game.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: It's kind of
like an all-in-one kind
of sensor device.
It doesn't only have
just the body movement
sensor, but also
has a microphone,
a camera, all the
different kinds of things.
So it could accurately
capture what you're doing.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So in
one rough sketch,
this is pretty much
all the sensors
that are incorporated into
the Xbox Kinect sensor.
As you can see, there's
a hand-tracking one
with the three
different options there.
Face-tracking, mic sensors-- all
of this is inside that little.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We don't actually
know what it's used for,
but there's also a glasses
tracking device sensor.
SWERY: Doesn't make sense.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So in order
to come to this point,
we've had a lot of different
input methods that we used.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
this is, basically,
all the different devices,
from the very beginning all
the way to 2014.
So all these devices have been
previously made up to now.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So basically,
at the very beginning,
if you look over there,
there's games that
only have a couple buttons.
And then we've progressed
all the way over here.
Do you know Femicon?
It's on the corner there, too.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Yeah, in the very
beginning of the 90's, there's
also this rifle controller
thing down here.
That's all very interesting.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: He
understands how much we all
love shooting games.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then, if you
look at the next decade over,
or the next
generation, you notice
that there's
actually controllers
device for each specific game.
So we have the new gun
controllers over here,
and then the actual handheld
controller over here,
specific to whatever game
that you are designing for.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And
then in this era,
you can see that they
also utilize a piano
keyboard up top.
So you use all different
kinds of medians
in order to play these games.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then,
in the 2000 onwards,
you noticed that we actually
have these kind of controllers.
Basically, everything
has some kind
of screen panel attached to it.
And then you have
guitars and drum sets,
and things that we see
nowadays in gaming.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: That's Kinect.
INTERPRETER: So the Kinect is
over here underneath the Wii.
So perhaps it's like whoever
made the slides preferences.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So probably
whenever we game nowadays,
we have something similar
to this, where you're
holding a handheld controller.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Also, the
other is like when you
use actual computer-- PC games.
And you have a mouse and
a keyboard to play with.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then also
nowadays, a particular style
is to use these kind of
things, like a pad over there,
or a guitar to play
the games nowadays.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So now we have
a question about Kinect.
Is it one of those games
that you have something
like a guitar in your
hand and you're playing,
or is it something
controller-based in your hand?
What do you think?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Anyone
that thinks that it's
like a gamepad device?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Something that's
very specific and different.
Anyone?
So there's two sides here.
We have a couple hands.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Some brave souls.
INTERPRETER: In his
opinion, he thinks
that Xbox One is traditional.
It's more traditional,
and not special.
It doesn't have those
different elements to it.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So in
his opinion, there's
two distinct differences
between a traditional game
and a not-so-traditional game.
The not-so-traditional
game would
be something that
does not-- you're not
designing the game based on
the medium that you're using.
And then the other
way around, if it's
a nontraditional device,
it is based-- sorry.
I got that wrong.
Sorry.
A traditional device
would be a game
that you play based
off of the medium
that you're using
to play the game.
And a nontraditional device is
not dependent upon the medium
that you're using,
but something else.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: He feels that a
special device-- a special game
would be something like, let's
say then Guitar Hero, when you
pick up a guitar, and you
have a guitar to play with,
you automatically know
that this is a music game.
It's not going to
be a fighting game.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We're going
to explain a little bit
about why the Kinect is
considered a traditional game.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So a game is made
by having the players input
a code through a different
medium into the game itself.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So the symbols--
like pushing this button will
fire this missile.
Kind of shorthand symbol.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
then in D4, instead
of actually having a
motion mean something,
it is more like you
follow the arrows.
So if you wanted to turn the
page, you follow the arrow,
and it will go around.
So it's like a symbol based.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So there's
also, like Minority Report
and Iron Man that came out,
it's not necessarily a game
that you use because it's
based off of this Kinect,
but kind of like a
halfway semi-using
the Apple products and
the OS, iOSes in order
to make the games.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So if you
kind of really focus into
whether you're going
to make a special game
or a traditional game, and
you narrow your vision,
your game is probably going
to become kind of small.
In his opinion, he
thinks that in order
to make it a bigger deal,
and make it a bigger thing,
you should break that boundary
between traditional and
special, and find
something that works really
well with the medium
that you're using.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So with
D4, what he wanted
to challenge was not only
the actual game play itself,
but how the players
interact with the device
in order to make actions happen.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
instead of having
the user have a handheld
controller to click on buttons,
he wanted to find a way that
you can actually have the people
interact with the game by
having these hand gestures,
or motioning a bat, and
having a story go along.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Are you interested?
INTERPRETER: Do you
have a preference?
Does anyone like
Kinect, particularly?
Hate Kinect?
Have an opinion about Kinect?
It's good?
I saw the-- over there.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So now
that we've piqued
your interest a
little bit, I think
that some people are
probably thinking,
yes, let's incorporate
motions into our game.
But actually there's a
bunch of little problems
that come up when you
want to use motion.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: The Kinect is,
as you see, stupidly honest.
It only registers the exact
motion that you are doing.
So you have to be precise
when you play this.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[LAUGHTER]
INTERPRETER:
There's a function--
especially like in D4, where if
you take from an outside hand
motion, and you
swipe to the left,
the camera will also follow you.
Your vision will change as well.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So let's
say if I was going
to swipe from my
right to my left,
the camera will move this way.
And if you move from
your left to the right,
the camera will move that way.
It didn't really work out.
Have you tried to do it?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So I know
some people probably
have this, if you're a gamer--
I know I've experienced this.
But if you try to
use one motion.
Like, OK, I'm going
to slide to the left.
That didn't work.
Let me try it again.
When you try it again, this
second sensor also catches.
So then your computer's just
moving around like crazy.
Instead of having
a one reset, it
registers this backwards
motion as well.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So in order
to try to compensate,
or to change this
method, he tried
to make it so that if
you swipe really fast,
the camera will react.
But if you swipe really
slow, it will not react.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: But at
first, he thought
this was a brilliant plan.
But when you're really
hyped up and energized
about playing a game, adrenaline
pumps in, and then everything
becomes really fast.
Or if you have maybe an older
person who maybe cannot move
their hand quite so fast.
It doesn't react.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
then he thought, OK,
let's try having a
little bit of time.
So once you move the camera
angle, if you don't do anything
you'll be OK.
It won't move.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So it didn't
work, because this speed
limitation was also one thing.
But once it--
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then,
even if you do something,
and then you're
like, OK, I'm going
to wait two seconds before
I do to my next action,
it actually just goes back
to what it was originally.
It reverts back.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So just from
this one swiping action,
he's changed it this many times.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So in the game D4,
in order to select something,
like back or next, you actually
have to grab the back or next.
There's a hand that
hovers, and then
he makes this grabbing
function, and it pushes "Enter"
pretty much.
But then, in order
to differentiate
between the swipe and
the grab-- or some
people do a combination
of a swipe and a grab
at the same time.
So it didn't work per se.
And so even if you're doing
one small action, like swiping,
it caused this much different
trial and errors that came up.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
what he wants to say
is that even though
there might be
some negative
views about Kinect,
it's just basically
maybe certain developers,
directors can't design
well for the game.
However, these things
could possibly easily
be overcome with
a software change.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And so if you try
to find a game designer who
doesn't think about
changing the software,
and actually only concentrates
on the hardware version of it,
then they're going to have
to make a game specifically
designed towards the
hardware, instead of having
the simple solution of let's
just change something else
to make it better.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So instead of how
to make a good game, instead
of thinking, "How do I use the
hardware that they've presented
me?" well, using that
hardware incorporating
a different software trying
to find a different approach
to make the hardware
itself more stand out
is what he wants to push.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Is it?
PROFESSOR: We're going to try.
INTERPRETER: Oh.
OK.
If this works, we can play D4.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Does
anyone want to play D4?
Oh.
Oh, oh yeah.
You all have to raise
your hand at the Kinect,
and it'll just
register everyone.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Anyone
whose name starts with D?
First name.
Like David, or
Diana, or Danielle?
SWERY: Nobody?
INTERPRETER: No one?
Really?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Last name?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
INTERPRETER: Yay!
SWERY: You can play.
Please.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: If it works.
Don't move too quickly.
Walk very slow.
Has anyone played D4?
SWERY: No?
Not yet?
INTERPRETER: I was supposed
to go to a meeting yesterday,
and instead I sat at my
house for six hours on my D4.
It's really addicting.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
maybe, as you said,
no one here has really
played this game.
But once you play it,
you'll know that this is not
your typical game.
It's a little bit different.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: But if this
doesn't work, it's affordable.
It's only $15.
Yay!
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
Thank you for PR!
[SPEAKING JAPANESE] Too dark.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Would
it be possible
if this doesn't work
to just do a Q&A now,
and then maybe set this
up in a different room
and have people play it?
PROFESSOR: There's no
other room that has HDMI,
especially a room that's
big enough for the class.
INTERPRETER: I see.
PROFESSOR: What I could
do is-- it wouldn't
work for today,
of course, but we
can do games in our game room.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, it's
supposed to look like that?
INTERPRETER: Yeah.
It has to look like that.
PROFESSOR: So it's the white.
There's a whole layer of
color that's not being shown.
AV PERSON: Right.
So if it looks fine
on that screen,
and then it doesn't look
fine on another screen,
then I can't say that it's the
connection that's the problem.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it could just be the--
AV PERSON: It's
possible it could
be the HDMI cable as well.
But there is two things
that I could suggest.
We could actually [INAUDIBLE].
INTERPRETER: Just
walk really slowly.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: And then
after-- [INAUDIBLE].
AV PERSON: We'll be
back in 5, 10 minutes.
PROFESSOR: 5, 10 minutes?
Great.
Cool.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: OK.
It was a really fun game.
Yeah!
So we're actually going to
try to do this one more time,
but we have about 5 or 10
minutes while they figure out
the technical aspects.
But if anyone has
any questions, we
can entertain them right now.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
adjustments to the software
that you made to
the Kinect firmware.
Is that something that--
is it very accessible?
Is it easy to change the
software that it comes with?
I would think Microsoft wouldn't
want people messing with--
and they muck it
up or something.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So it's actually
pretty easy to change,
apparently, the software part.
But in order to think about how
it could be better-- like why
it's buggy, or what
could be better--
what could make it smoother,
in order to even make D4,
it took three years.
So coming up with all
the different things
that could possibly go
wrong is more of an issue.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You mentioned the
problem with the camera.
How did you finally fix it?
INTERPRETER: Which?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: He mentioned the
problem with the camera.
How did he finally fix it?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So basically,
it's just a bazillion trials
and errors, asking people--
like any users, hey,
let's play Testament a bazillion
times over, and just trying
to somehow come up
with the solution.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So actually,
with the Kinect,
it registers everyone's height
and weight kind of things.
So if you go to
Japan, where everyone
tends to be a little
bit vertically smaller,
as opposed to if you
go to America, Europe,
and the people tend to
be a little bit bigger.
So he has to go to all
these different countries
and have play tests done
at those specific countries
in order to adjust
for physical problems.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the input device
affecting how you
design your game.
What would you do if you had
a brain-computer interface?
INTERPRETER: You would
laugh, apparently.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So he actually
wants to challenge it sometime.
But even with the
motion sensors,
you have so many problems
that are going on.
So as a game designer, if you
were to use the brain sensor
ones, you'd have to even
think of one step even ahead
of the player in
order to get it to go.
So it'd probably
be very difficult.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: But
even in D4, when
we have even like an
arrow, people, humans,
we tend to automatically
follow the arrow anyways.
So if there's just an
arrow and no directions,
you just kind of
follow the arrow.
So perhaps there is
a way to actually
have it so that we can
do the brain sensors,
because of existing
motor recognition.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that you have
this more generalized input
devices and specific input
devices.
What's your opinion on that?
Even for the generalized
input devices, some of them
are better for some
games and not others.
For example, keyboard and
mouse works well for strategy,
but you can't really
do StarCraft II
with a standard controller.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So his opinion
is it doesn't really
change based on having one
set-- the design for what
you want to make.
But as a designer,
you definitely
should think about which
one is going to work better.
As you said, StarCraft would
not really work so well
with a handheld controller.
And so that's kind
of up to the designer
to decide whichever is better.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So we're
not trying to be like,
"Go play Kinect, everyone!"
But it's more of
instead of having
this is one option,
by using the Kinect,
how can we make it so
that the user actually
feels more like they
are playing in the game,
actually, controlling
the character,
and having different
options that way?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: You?
AUDIENCE: So I found
it really interesting
how you talked about
the differences
between the different
kinds of controllers,
and what you just
said about having
to think carefully about
which controls do you use.
Is there something about
the Kinect's motion
detection that you
think really contributed
to the feel or the
atmosphere of the game?
And then you talked a
little bit about immersion,
but something maybe a
little more specific
than that-- something
that you feel
like, because I used
the Kinect, I really
got to do something
specifically cool?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So
with the D4 game,
let's say if you
wanted to use a mouse,
and you can actually follow
the mouse with the arrows,
or use the control of the
D-pad and follow around
with the arrows.
But with Kinect,
what is really cool
is that you can
actually move your hand
and click on something,
or do an action based off
of Kinect functions.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So let's
say by using the Kinect,
there is-- it's kind
of easier if you
have played this before--
as with everything.
But there are
certain things that
happen-- like real-time,
different events that
are triggered because of another
thing that you have done.
And with Kinect, it's
actually smoother.
Like your emotions, if you feel
really on edge about something,
it kind of reflects in
your body movements,
and then it catches that.
So with the Kinect,
there's a little bit more
in your personal-- like you're
in the game kind of thing,
as opposed to a controller.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then, so if you
had a controller in your hand,
or a mouse or a
keyboard, the only way
to make something harder--
to raise difficulty--
is to increase the
speed of your tapping,
or something has to--
that kind of thing.
There might be other ways.
But for the most part,
we increase the speed.
However, with the Kinect
you actually physically
have to emotionally gut
yourself into it in order for it
to increase.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Oh.
SWERY: You?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In my experience with
these kind of things
where you have no
direct control over what
several users may have-- like
you talked about the grandma
and speed up.
So, in my experience,
the way you do it is you
make sure that
that is a variable.
And I'm asking, why is
it not possible here?
So, for example,
before the game starts,
you ask the grandma to
register how fast she
can do this with the camera.
INTERPRETER: Oh.
Like a Windows
double-click speed testing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
So you set up all those
things as variables.
And when the game starts the
grandma can go at her pace,
the young guy can
go at his pace.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
You can in D4.
In D4 you can.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: But they still
took an average, pretty much.
So most people would be
able to still play it
without having to finagle
though all the settings.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
Any other question?
AUDIENCE: What's the cost
for an average game that,
say, like cost, like D4?
What's the cost in
terms of capital,
number of people you need--
developers, artists, whatever?
INTERPRETER: You want a very
large number, basically.
AUDIENCE: How long would
it take to develop a game?
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: Oh.
INTERPRETER: Many zeroes.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So it's
kind of difficult to put
a number to how much it costs.
This is kind of hard for
me explain, so bear with me
a moment.
But if you were to say
how many people were
to work on this game,
and then kind of use that
as a monetary
equation, in one month
if you were going
to make this game,
you'd probably have
about 600 peoples' worth.
Does that make sense?
So if you only had 20
people, and 20 people worked
on one game for one
month, it would maybe
take 30 months to finish
this game kind of thing.
Does that make sense?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So D4 is
still a smaller-- it's not
a huge, giant, giant game.
So if you go to maybe
PlayStation, like a big company
game, it might be 300
people, one month,
for 30 months kind of thing.
So it kind of depends.
And it's a roundabout,
not really a good answer.
But--
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Yes!
It's working!
Finally!
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Yay!
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Color.
Can everyone see?
If you can't, you could
consolidate, probably.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Binoculars.
INTERPRETER: So you have to move
your hand, and pick and grab.
Yeah.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Yes.
The action is good.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: There might
be some graphic morals,
or graphic language.
I hope we're all OK.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
Get out here now!
[PUNCH]
[PUNCHES AND GRUNTS]
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
[INAUDIBLE].
Set your ass on your head!
No more messing with me, Papi!
[GRUNTS]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: Bad.
Real bad!
[INAUDIBLE] I said.
You're never, ever,
ever gonna [INAUDIBLE].
INTERPRETER: That's
the main character.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
There you are.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hey, Papi!
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
So how about--
SWERY: Action.
INTERPRETER: Oh.
And this is the action.
You have to move
your right hand down.
There.
[SOUNDS OF FIGHT]
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Things just got serious!
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE], I'm walking
this one down to the park.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So it
wasn't used here,
but there's actually moments
where you scream into the mic--
the sensor in the
microphone-- to catch it.
Yeah.
You'll have a little command on
the side that says, "Scream."
And you're like "Ah!"
And it goes whoop.
Like, OK!
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So we're kind
of running low on time.
So he's going to do
the adventure one.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Thank
you for laughing.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: The
loading time, however,
is something we cannot overcome.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So this
adventure scene, we're
just going to show you how
to investigate the rooms
themselves.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So he has a special
ability to go back in time.
And just now, when he fell,
he just came back from back
in time.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So by
using Kinect, you
can interact with the characters
by using these hand signals.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then
there's an exclamation point.
If you hover your
hand over it, you'll
be able to see
important information.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: He's a detective.
Basically, his wife was
killed two years ago,
and he's looking for the
true murderer of the case.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
My name is David Young.
Former narc with the Boston PD.
INTERPRETER: It takes
place in Boston, too!
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: My likes
include 100% agave tequila.
My dislikes are mainly
drugs and chewing gum.
Two years ago someone
killed my wife.
Since then I've been using
every second of my life
to solve the case.
SWERY: My name!
INTERPRETER: That's him!
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Just by
moving your hand around,
you can pick which one you
actually want to interact with.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then, if
you clasp your hand together,
it's enter.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And if you follow
the movement of the arrow,
it moves the character's hand.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: It's
been broken since that day.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: You
can use both hands.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: If you wanted
to change the camera angle,
you put your hand all the way
to the side and swipe across.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then if
you tried to swipe it twice,
it'd be
back-forth-back-forth-back-forth
instead of having this basically
holding it and sliding over.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Of course,
you're not actually
shutting something physical.
But by using the
arrows, you kind of
have the feeling that you are
shutting the toilet seat down.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: In
a slightly different form.
Like all these forgotten
treasures, mementos.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: OK.
Put your hands up,
it closes the screen.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: We're going
to skip this serious part
and just go into action.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: No
results this time either.
This case is in the clear.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So there's a
lot of things in the rooms
that you can interact with.
And if you're not sure
which one you should do,
if you put your
hand like this, it
activates a thing called
Vision, which is actually
voice-commanded also.
You can say "Vision on,"
and it will turn on.
And it shows you the
different options of what
you could pick up or touch.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So usually
with the controller,
you use like Y button or
something to enter something.
But with the Kinect, by
using an actual hand gesture
you can connect with that
even better, the characters.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
There's only one thing
I need at the moment.
Tequila.
Straight up.
SWERY: Me too.
INTERPRETER: Him, too.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: If you had to do
a gesture every few seconds,
it might get kind of annoying.
But as you see, it's
like spaced out.
It's only occasionally
you do these gestures.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: This
is his dead wife.
WIFE IN VIDEO GAME: Maybe
I'll just try a little.
Oh!
[LAUGHING]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Yeah.
Everything he does
is very violent.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: I have
no memories of that day.
When I came to, I was
already lying in the ICU.
The only thing I do remember
are the words that little Peggy
whispered as she died.
"Look for 'D.'" Who is "D"?
INTERPRETER: Which
we tried to do.
But no one's name
started with "D."
So sad!
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
At the time,
there's no compelling evidence.
[INAUDIBLE]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: Such
a depressing story.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: Under
the right circumstances,
I now have the capability to
solve even a dead-end case.
INTERPRETER: He even
has an accent, though.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
I'll do everything
in my power to find this "D."
I swear I will.
And when I do, oh, Peggy.
Amanda?
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So we're going
to investigate this door.
Huh!
[MEOW]
[MEOWING]
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: And then
he's going to [INAUDIBLE]
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER:
You can't escape now.
[MEOW]
[MEOWING]
This is Amanda.
She just suddenly started--
INTERPRETER: And you
can move your body
and change the camera angle.
VIDEO GAME CHARACTER: Sometimes
goes out and gets food for us.
And that's something
of a lifeline for me,
because I don't
really go outside.
Just who she is, though-- well,
my memory holds no answers.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: That's the end.
SWERY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
INTERPRETER: Again, the game
does take place in Boston,
so it's kind of adorable.
BPD comes out.
SWERY: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERPRETER: So if
you can get a chance
to maybe play around
with it sometime,
it would be wonderful.
If you can experiment
around with what
we talked about today, and
see how the interaction
will change your game-play.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[CROWD NOISE]